i was living in san francisco pursuing
my interests of photography and
sculpture
ceramic sculpture
and i
was making my living by working with
bands
i did stage work for bands i did album
covers for bands i worked at a
performance art
space setting up for different musical
groups
and at the same time i was seeing many
many many movies i was
saw all the for frederico fellini's
movies um
and they really had a visual impact on
my
life and i went to see one movie by vim
venders
and i watched that movie and i thought
to myself what i am doing for the bands
is really like a setup that is in this
movie
and i thought well maybe there's some
kind of job uh that i could do maybe
maybe this is a field that exists in the
real world
so i started doing a research project
and i asked everybody i knew nobody knew
anything about production design or art
direction or set decoration or anything
so i
did research in the library and i you
know
you know there was no online so i i um
tried to talk to as many people as i
could and i realized that living in san
francisco there was a very small film
community and there really wasn't any
way that i was going to be breaking in
and entering into the movie business so
i moved to los angeles and the first
project i got involved with was a film
at afi i volunteered to be part of the
art department on this small film and
that year that film went on to be
nominated for best short subject and
from then on it was the people that i
met and the type of projects that they
were working on and friends of friends
and introductions and
i was
on my way
i think they view the set decorator as
kind of a glamorous
job
that you you know
take a lot of meetings and spend tons of
money and you're always shopping and
just buying things all the time
where there's a lot
of different aspects of the decorating
job you have to work with budget you
have to work with a lot of personalities
you have to work with a large team of
people that are actually making the
movie from the director to the
cinematographer the producers and the
actors because all these people really
influence
the environments that you are creating
for the film and in essence we are
creating an environment
for the action
when i first started making movies we
would just
figure out the sets and from a drawing
and we would just build the sets and
dress the sets
now there is so much preparation that
goes
before you even start filming there's
pre-visualization of the action scenes
that are needed there's many more
storyboarding uh sequences
there's breaking down the movie to
what's visual effects and what's live
action and it's
much more of a
many more teams are involved than used
to be involved so it's a little bit more
complicated and it's way more about
money
way more about money and budgeting and
how much money you're spending and are
you coming in on budget and what they
can get for the money
and if you are not good with money it's
you have to be creative but you have to
be great with money
you